Moin, Leute.
Pogu.
Poyda, du bist auch immer am Start, oder?
Ich habe dich die letzten Streams schon quasi immer instant im Chat gesehen.
Massive Chatting Skills.
So, alles klar.
Ich muss gerade noch was gucken auf dem zweiten Bildschirm.
Eigentlich ist mein Vorschau-Rechner immer noch total overkill für einfach nur Vorschau-Rechner.
Aber ich will mich ja mal nicht beschweren.
Besser zu viel Vorschau-Rechner als zu wenig Vorschau-Rechner.
Projektdokumentation.
Was schreibst du denn?
Bestimmt für die Abschlussprüfung, oder?
Was hast du für ein Thema?
Was hast du für ein Thema in der Abschlussprüfung?
Äh, in deiner... für dein Projekt.
Für dein Abschlussprojekt.
Ich glaube, es gibt kaum einer, der weiter entfernt ist,
Vollzeit-Streamer zu werden, beziehungsweise zu wollen als ich.
Also, jemand aus diesem Twitch-YouTube-Ökosystem, ja.
Also, der 0815-Dude um die Ecke wahrscheinlich weniger, aber...
Ich hab da keine Ambitionen.
Ach so.
Okay, kein Abschlussprojekt.
Keck bei.
Könntest du von YouTube und Twitch leben?
Also, so wie ich es jetzt aktuell mache?
Nee, auf gar keinen Fall.
Zumindest, sag mal, ich könnte vielleicht überleben davon.
Also, ich könnte mir wahrscheinlich zu essen kaufen und ich könnte heizen oder so.
Aber ich könnte sonst wahrscheinlich wenig machen.
Auf der anderen Seite, wenn ich Vollzeit machen würde, dann würde ich wahrscheinlich pro Woche auch zwei, drei...
Wahrscheinlich eher drei Videos machen.
Und wahrscheinlich täglich streamen und mehr Sponsorships und irgendwelche anderen Kooperationssachen machen.
Dann vielleicht.
Aber, also, sag mal so, mit dem, was jetzt unterm Strich rauskommt, könntest du halbwegs überleben, aber nicht wirklich gut von leben.
Doch, wenn ich jeden Tag ein Video mache und Sponsorship mache oder so, dann bestimmt.
Aber das sehe ich jetzt nicht als the way für mich.
Außerdem habe ich da gar keinen Bock drauf, gezwungenermaßen Content machen zu müssen.
Nicht, da ich wirklich jeden Tag streamen würde, jeden Tag Videos machen würde, also jeden zweiten Tag Videos machen würde.
Viel mehr Sponsorings annehmen und Sellout machen, alle möglichen Geschichten.
Muss ich schon eine Patreon-Seite und alles, was du nicht gesehen, machen?
Doch, klar, wahrscheinlich, höchstwahrscheinlich schon.
Aber habe ich überhaupt keinen Bock drauf.
Mir ist das so viel lieber.
Normaler Job, dafür Teilzeit dort und hier, wie ich Bock habe.
Ich muss halt nicht.
Das ist das Gute.
Das ist unglaublich beruhigend, wenn du weißt, du musst weder das eine noch das andere machen.
Ja, also, wenn dich das eine nervt, könntest du das andere machen und umgedreht.
Also, Wohnung habe ich ja eh nicht das Problem.
Ich muss ja keine Miete bezahlen.
Was hältst du eigentlich von Zappix?
Ich finde Zappix gut.
Ich habe Zappix bei mir daheim auch im Einsatz.
Ich muss sagen, Zappix ist halt vom Webinterface und der Konfiguration im Webinterface ziemlich abartig.
Beziehungsweise muss ich erst mal an die Zappix Logik gewöhnen und dass sie Sachen so nennen, aber es nicht unbedingt das ist, wie es benannt ist und so.
Das ist ganz merkwürdig.
Aber Zappix ist eine gute Sache, wenn man quasi was haben will mit Webinterface zum Konfigurieren und wo du mehr machen kannst als mit Uptime Kuma.
Also, wenn einem das pure Pingen, Up, Down, Anzeige oder halt auch einfache Statuswerte nicht reicht.
Wenn man zum Beispiel Notifications haben will.
Wenn die Festplatte voll läuft.
Oder wenn man vielleicht auch mal zwei, drei Wochen History haben will, rückwärts gucken will.
Also, wenn da Uptime Kuma nicht reicht, ist Zappix eine super Geschichte.
Die Prometheus Grafana Kombi ist eher so, wir bauen unser Monitoring selbst, was ja auch seine Daseinsberechtigung hat.
Und es sind ja auch zwei unterschiedliche Ansätze.
Prometheus ist ursprünglich mal dafür entwickelt worden, damit man Anwendungsmetriken einsammeln kann.
Nicht so sehr.
Wie ist die CPU-Auslastung auf der Linux-Kiste?
Kann man auch machen.
Aber ich finde, man merkt schon, wo das herkommt.
Deswegen ist Zappix, Zappix ist nicht verkehrt.
Hast du eigentlich auch Pläne, was smartes Energiemanagement angeht mit Solaren?
Nee, habe ich nicht.
Ich werde in nächster Zeit kein Photovoltaik-Zeug aufs Dach bauen lassen.
Liegt an mehreren Gründen.
Die Lage ist ganz okay.
Aber man kommt halt sehr schlecht ans Dach dran.
Das heißt, da muss wahrscheinlich Gerüst gebaut werden.
Das ist ein Riesenakt.
Am Ende bezahle ich dann irgendwie 30.000 Euro oder so für eine Installation.
Da habe ich ehrlich gesagt keinen Bock drauf.
Bis ich das jemals wieder eingespart habe, sind wahrscheinlich die ersten Panels kaputt oder so.
Und selbst wenn es einem nur auf so plus minus null geht, selbst dann, dafür ist es eigentlich zu teuer.
Dementsprechend habe ich da keine Ambitionen, was das angeht.
Hast du noch Kontakt zum Friseur?
Unregelmäßig, ja.
Ich glaube vor einem Monat oder so habe ich das letzte Mal mit ihm geschrieben im Discord.
Weiß jemand, wie ich meinen TP-Link EAP245 Access Point optimieren kann?
Was?
Was meinst du mit optimieren?
Achso, naja, ich weiß nicht, was man auf den Dingern einstellen kann.
Das erste, was ich mal prinzipiell ausprobieren würde, wie gut ist denn die Übertragungsrate, wenn man direkt neben dem Access Point steht?
Das ist das erste, wo ich mal gucken würde.
So.
Weil, je nachdem, was in deiner Um...
Also wenn du nur 80 MBit Down bekommst, was kann denn der Access Point?
Was ist das für ein Access Point?
Also was geht denn da maximal?
Also brauchst du natürlich auch das passende Endgerät dafür, logischerweise, ja.
Also 80 MBit Down ist schon ein bisschen wenig.
Also ich krieg mit meinem hier irgendwie so 100, 160, 170 MBit.
Und das ist schon nicht wirklich einer der neuesten.
Hä, 100?
Verwendet man 100 überhaupt?
WLAN-technisch darfst du mich nichts fragen.
WLAN-technisch habe ich wenig Ahnung.
Ja.
Kein Plan.
Guck mir lieber zum Beruhigen der Runde Askiquarium jetzt an.
Aber viele Access Points haben so einen automatischen Optimierungsmodus, wo die gucken, welche Kanäle frei sind.
Und dann darauf switchen.
Das könnte man vielleicht mal machen.
Habt ihr im Büro auch laufen, Beste?
Naja.
Naja, Pläne habe ich im Prinzip dahingehend, dass ich mich damit beschäftigt habe und es nicht aktiv plane, das zu machen.
Das sind meine Pläne dazu.
Ja.
Also ich zeige euch mal kurz, was wir heute machen.
Stream.
Ja.
Korrekt.
Hogu-Stream.
Oh, Sekunde.
Ich muss mal kurz mein Headset entknoten.
Ich bin gleich wieder am Start.
So.
Da bin ich wieder.
Exzellent.
Also.
Was machen wir heute?
Weiß ich, ob Modgis schon da ist?
Irgendeiner der Modgis?
Ja, doch.
Der Serious Max ist da.
Der ist immer richtig, richtig high IQ, was Daily-Zusammenfassungsschreiben angeht.
Also, was wir heute machen, ist, wir gucken uns Folgendes an.
Und zwar.
Nein, nicht.
Nicht.
Oh, nicht Headset entklaut.
Boah.
Mein Auge.
Sekunde.
Oh.
Nein, nein.
estarbyan.
Ihr versteht mich nicht alle.
S guaranteed.
Es peint nicht, dass ihr mich schickt.
Nee.
Das heißt euer contact.
Ist kein contact,ocker.
Das heißt folgende.
Es geht nicht mehr gut.
Das heißt, Microsoft hatnightmaid.
Ja, es geht nicht gut.
Bis da.
Unterm Start.
Returns.
Wir machen da mal was and气e Madonna.
Und da waren vittuos.
Und da folgen eingriffen soll.
Kannst sowas?
Wo?
Diese.
war im november und da ist jemand auf eine sehr schlaue idee gekommen und zwar
der hat eine übungsseite gebaut nicht für irgendwelchen hacker kram oder
irgendwelches kryptographie zeug oder oder programmierstelle leadcode gedöns
nein der ist auf die idee gekommen warum bauen wir nicht mal so eine challenge
beziehungsweise test übungsseite für linux administration und devops themen
und da hat er uns aber so hauptsächlich hauptsächlich linux linux skills skills
und da hat er setzer was punkt kommt gebaut und da gibt es unter
unterschiedlich schwere herausforderungen die man in einer
vorgegebenen zeitspanne schaffen muss also guckt mal guckt können euch banken
also was ist zum beispiel gibt es aktuell gibt es 17 verschiedene tests die
man machen kann zwischen easy und zehn minuten zu schwer und bis zu 30 minuten
ich würde sagen wir fangen einfach
von oben nach unten an ja ich muss sagen ich mache das nicht ganz planlos
ich habe mir manche aufgaben stellungen und sachen schon im vorfeld angeguckt
auf dem smartphone smartphone als ich mal morgens im zug gehockt habe als ich
das da kann ich mich noch daran erinnern da habe ich morgens im zug bisschen
durchgescrollt wo man das terminal im zug nicht gescheit bedienen konnte und
da gibt es aufgaben da gibt es dann zum beispiel aufgaben wie du hast also level
easy du hast zehn minuten zeit und zur info
siehst du okay aufgabe ist folgendes
hier auf diesem server läuft ein
programm was eine logdatei schreibt war log bed lock.log und was die festplatte
voll schreibt und das kann man hier mit überprüfen und das ziel ist es dass das
programm quasi für bis zu sechs sekunden also der test der man am ende durchführt
kann ist das das programm sechs
sekunden lang nicht in die logdatei drauf geschrieben hat das fängt relativ
simpel an ich war wieder ein bisschen was bedienungs bisher zu tun hatte wird sich
denken können ja gut ps aux grepp oder ls wenig nicht nicht f user ls auf oder irgendwas auf die
datei gucken was es ist den prozess abschließen und dann ist wieder gut aber das wird dann mit
der zeit schon ein bisschen komplexer ja da gibt es dann irgendwann super medium kommen dann solche
aufgaben wie hier zum beispiel es gibt hier eine web application mit einem proxy davor und der
proxy funktioniert nicht richtig man soll raus bekommen woran das liegt dass die anwendung nicht
richtig erreichbar ist also das geht von easy die teilweise wirklich easy sind von der aufgaben
beschreibung her zu doch schon relativ relativ kompliziert ja zum beispiel solche geschichten
wie docker container kann nicht zur datenbank container und sowas also das fängt einfach an
ist dann aber spätestens spätestens am medium nichts mehr was man innerhalb von einer minute
mal easy bei easy nebenbei
mal kurz einmal angeguckt man weiß sofort finde ich ist eine super idee weil mir ist nichts bekannt
wo man so ein bisschen somit mit vordefinierten ausgaben vordefinierten aufgaben und auch tests
am ende wirklich ein bisschen so seine linux skills testen kann hätte es vor ein paar jahren gegeben
guck mal das ist auch ganz neue und hätte es das vor ein paar jahren gegeben hätte ich mal unsere
azubis immer so dinger machen lassen
als minus kuh übung zum reinkommen bestimmt ich gehe davon aus dass es spätestens ab medium gar nicht mehr sosome des also was hier gelesen habe zum beispiel so was hier war das glaube ich genau die datei home admin zamm feil wird es wird geschrieben von irgendeinem prozess und man soll die datei schließen ohne dass sie geschrumpft ist also das ist eine
super da puß
protokoll
schließen
ohne dass die datei schließe
geht
schließe
wirklich
ohne dass die datei schließe
dass man den Prozess abschießt, da muss man wahrscheinlich irgendein Signal an den Prozess
senden oder sowas, müssen wir uns da mal angucken, aber das ist dann schon ein bisschen
trickreicher, also sprich, wie kriege ich das Ding dazu, dass die Logdatei freigegeben
wird, ohne dass ich den Prozess abschieße, das kann ja auch durchaus ein realistisches
Szenario sein, überlegt euch mal, ihr habt irgendeine Anwendung, irgendeine produktive
Anwendung, die gigabyteweise Logs schreibt und ihr wollt die dazu auffordern, rotier
mal deine Logs oder mach mal ein neues Log, weil die Platte voll läuft, also das ist
gar kein so unrealistisches Szenario, oder was haben wir hier, DNS, can't ping google.com,
das kann ja potenziell alles sein, ping google.com, name of service unknown, das kann ja prinzipiell
alles sein, also woran auch immer das liegt, ja, can you nixponton, gute Idee, das machen
wir nachher.
Gucken wir, gucken wir uns nachher eine Runde Unixporn an, gatschibass, jetzt müssen wir
erstmal ein paar Server glücklich machen, ja, also und so ist das Ganze aufgebaut, ich
finde, das ist eine super Idee von dem Typ, gab doch auf Discord einen Aufruf aus der
Community, ich war seit gestern nicht mehr auf Discord drauf, ich hab noch nicht auf
Discord drauf geguckt, keine Ahnung, ich lecke Critical Information, ich hab keine Ahnung,
was es da gibt, es gibt einen neuen Channel dafür.
Ich guck da mal kurz rein, Sekunde, Leute, ähm, Unixporn, Bilder-only-Channels, Max macht
morgen im Stream, hab ich das tatsächlich gesagt, dass ich das morgen im Stream, fuck
Alter, wie viel da drin ist, ja, okay, gucken wir uns, gucken wir uns nachher an, ja, falls
ich irgendwie das wieder ignorieren sollte und verdrängen sollte, erinnert mich mal dran,
ich, ich schreib's mir, ich schreib's mir extra mal auf, dass ich's am Ende nicht vergesse,
ja, Unixporn.
Aus Discord, alles klar, so machen wir das.
Ja, was weiß ich, was ich gestern im Stream alles erzählt hab, ich mein, Leute, ich rede
da drei bis vier Stunden teilweise ohne Unterbrechung, was weiß ich, was ich da irgendwie mal in
einem Nebensatz gesagt habe, was ich angeblich mache, das war jetzt auch einen Tag später
nicht mehr, ne, jetzt machen wir erstmal ZG-Server, die sind nämlich alle sehr traurig gerade
und müssen von uns gefixt werden, ja.
Das können wir nicht tolerieren, dass die Linux-Server traurig sind.
So, also übrigens, es gibt ein GitHub-Projekt dazu, FDuran, Set Servers, hätte durchaus
noch ein paar Sterne verdient, also Leute, tut euch, wenn, wenn, wenn euch dieser Service
gefällt, ja, tut euch keinen Zwang an, gebt ihm ein paar Sterne auf GitHub und ich würde
sagen, wir probieren das einfach mal, wir gucken uns das Ganze jetzt einfach mal an.
Also Chat, wenn ihr Fragen habt, beziehungsweise wenn ihr Ideen habt, wenn ich nicht weiß,
wie es weiterkommen sollte oder so, ihr dürft auch backseaten, wie ihr wollt heute.
Okay, was heißt, wie ihr wollt?
Ja, ihr dürft backseaten, wie ihr wollt, wenn es mir auf den Sack geht, kann es aber
sein, dass ich euch time-oute.
Also da weiß ich nie so genau, manchmal regt es mich ja auf, aber so prinzipiell dürft
ihr so viel backseaten, wie ihr wollt und ich glaube, man hat verstanden, um was es
geht, oder?
Aber ich meine, wir können uns ja nochmal anschauen, kurz, kurz angucken, was der Typ
selbst über den, über den Service.
Der schreibt, der schreibt hier, ähm, Lead Code for, äh, for Linux.
Trouble, shoot and make a Z-Server happy.
Guck, aktuell ist der Server äußerst, äußerst Z-ge und danach ist der Server white people
happy.
Was ist backseaten?
Ich würde jetzt ja eigentlich Chat-GPT fragen.
What's, what's backseating?
Ähm, aber ich fürchte.
Ich fürchte, meine Session ist abgelaufen.
B-A-G, B-A-G-seating vor allem.
Okay, ich fürchte, meine Session ist tatsächlich wieder abgelaufen.
Keine Ahnung.
Backseating ist, wenn jemand was macht im Stream und der Chat versucht, ihm die ganze
Zeit, oder versucht, ihm die ganze Zeit zu erzählen, was er denn jetzt als nächstes
machen soll.
Ja?
Zum Beispiel, stell dir vor, irgendjemand spielt ein Spiel, kommt nicht weiter und der
Chat sagt ihm im Sekundentakt, was er jetzt machen soll und meistens, und das ist ja das
Fatale beim Backseating.
Meistens hat der Chat.
Meistens hat der Chat noch weniger Ahnung von der ganzen Sache als der Streamer selbst.
Der Chat hat einfach nur, ist einfach nur nervig am Backseaten dann.
Genau.
Das ist zum Beispiel, das könnte man schon als Backseating interpretieren.
Okay, also wir fangen jetzt mal an, gucken wir uns das Ganze mal, also ZG-Servers.
Wir fangen oben an.
Wir machen die easy Variante.
Also wir fangen an mit Sankt, Saint, nee, Saint John.
What's writing to this log file?
Run.
Ja, danke.
Aber die coole Sache daran ist, ich habe mir ja ein bisschen hier durchgelesen bei Hacker
News, was der Typ macht.
Man bekommt, das steht ja auch hier glaube ich irgendwo.
Man bekommt einen echten AWS, eine echte AWS Linux VM.
Moin, wie geil, dass du Chat-GPT direkt an der Hand hast.
Gibt es eine Möglichkeit, das zu nutzen, ohne seine Handynummer angeben zu müssen?
Nee.
Registrieren musst du dich so.
Du kannst aber, du kannst aber, ähm.
Wenigstens das ohne API-Key machen.
Also du kannst, du kannst zum Beispiel das hier verwenden auf dem, auf dem Terminal.
Da kannst du Chat-GPT-Wrapper, kannst du sowas hier zum Beispiel verwenden.
Das ist ein Kommandozeilentool, was quasi einen Browser simuliert und so tut, als, beziehungsweise
kein Browser simuliert, einen Browser fernsteuert und die Antworten dann ins Terminal haut.
Also quasi wie wenn du einen Browser aufmachst und direkt auf den Terminal gehst.
Aber du brauchst einen Account, das geht nicht anders.
Okay, Leute, also geht los.
Wir haben zehn Minuten Zeit, wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe für die Challenge.
Also, time to solve ten minutes.
Übrigens, Leute, wenn man es in zehn Minuten nicht geschafft hat, dann wird einfach der
Server wieder gelöscht.
Also du musst es in zehn Minuten schaffen.
Das liegt einfach daran, der Typ, der will ja auch nicht unendlich Geld für seine AWS-VMs
bezahlen.
Deswegen ist das alles zeitlich, zeitlich beschränkt.
Das ist nicht Arschloch.
Ja, deswegen ist es ja auch zeitlich beschränkt.
Okay, also instructions, Terminal aufmachen.
Okay, nice.
Machen wir kurz ein bisschen ein bisschen größere Schrift, dass ihr auch dann ordentlich
seht.
Also, Beschriftung.
Äh Description.
Level easy, description.
Also, ein Entwickler, NAVIC.
Leute, Leute, weißt du was wir machen?
Pfeiffer-Time
Guck mal, für euch
Für euch machen wir das jetzt
Diepel
Ach fuck, ich will ja von Englisch zu
Englisch
Dann übersetzen wir es
Mit der
Webseite
Ein Entwickler hat ein Testprogramm
Erstellt, das kontinuierlich
In eine Protokolldatei
Schreibt
Und die Festplatte füllt
Sie können dies zum Beispiel
Tale-f-wahl-log-dings überprüfen
Dieses Programm wird nicht mehr benötigt
Finden sie es und beenden sie es
Das ist relativ easy, ich glaube das kriegen wir einfach hin
Wir sehen, okay, auf dem Server
Gibt es ein
Eine Logdatei, wo permanent reingespampt wird
Ja, der Chat
Schon wieder am Backseaten
Aber wenn es ausatmet, gibt es Timeouts
Ich sag es euch
Ihr dürft Backseaten, aber ihr müsst die feine
Den feinen
Den feinen Grad finden
Zwischen Backseaten
Und mir auf den Sack gehen
Und nachdem es ja irgendwie keine Anzeige gibt
Auf welcher Seite ich gerade bin
Ist Backseating quasi immer nur
Auf eigene Gefahr
Ja, danke für den Sub
So, also
Von der Idee her relativ einfach
Wir können zum Beispiel mal
Ja, wir können zum Beispiel mal gucken
Was läuft denn da so
Wir können hier mal gucken, ob da irgendwas drin auftaucht
Also ich meine, die einfachste
Ich zeige euch gleich, wie man es ordentlich macht
Oder wie ich denke, dass man es ordentlich macht
Also sieht man hier zum Beispiel links großartig
Wir können zum Beispiel mal PSAugs gucken
Crap, Bad
Ach guck mal, da läuft ja schon was
Badlog.py
Okay, das wird es wahrscheinlich sein
Allerdings
Die einfachste Variante ist NSOff
Chat ist im Weg
Ja, der Chat
Der Chat ist im Weg
Eigentlich ist der Chat
Ne, der Chat ist meistens nicht im Weg
Der Chat ist hier unten rechts
Ich weiß eben, war es im Weg
Aber das wird wahrscheinlich nicht so oft der Fall sein
Chat bleibt trotzdem eingeblendet
So, gehen wir mal ins Heimatverzeichnis
Slack ein bisschen
So, Badlog.py haben wir hier
Und dann machen wir NSOff
Auf
NSOff
Warlog Badlog
Und da sehen wir, okay
Es ist tatsächlich
Badlog.py
Was da drauf zugreift
Das heißt, wir können jetzt folgendes machen
Entweder
Sagen wir Kill633
Also hier, die Prozess-ID
Oder wir sagen
Äh, Kivo, mach dir keine Gedanken
Der Chat ist wieder ein bisschen am rum
Rumchibäden
Ich hab damit keine Schmerzen mit
Wenn mich einer darauf hinweist, dass der Chat über dem Text ist
So, ähm
Oder wir sagen
Killall
Badlog.py
Wenn das jetzt allerdings mehrfach laufen würde
Dann würden wir alles abschießen
Was NSOff macht
Das guckt, welche Filehandles offen sind
Guckt, was die sagen
List Open Files
Guckt, ob es Filehandles gibt
Auf die
Auf die Datei
Und zeigt dir an
Was da drauf zugreift
Und jetzt haben wir es eigentlich gefixt, würde ich sagen
So, tail-f
Und wir sehen, dass wir nichts mehr sehen
Dass nichts mehr reingeschrieben wird
Okay
Dann lasst uns mal checken, ob wir recht haben
Check my solution
Korrekt
Easy
Easy as fuck
Geh davon aus, dass nicht alles so einfach sein wird
Okay
Jetzt restliche Zeit meinen
Ich glaube, man hat keinen Internetzugriff
Man hat, man hat keinen Internetzugriff
Funktioniert nicht
Okay, ähm, der schreibt irgendwie, dass man die
VM ausschalten soll hier
Also, sudo poweroff
Connection closed
Next
Also, erstes war tatsächlich easy
Ich behaupte mal, wir haben nicht mal ansatzweise 10 Minuten gebraucht
Ah, ich hab, hab ich, meinst du, ich hab jetzt ganz AWS runtergefahren?
Ja
Ich glaube, ich ruf mal kurz bei der Amazon Hotline an
Okay, nächstes
Counting IPs
Run
So, was haben wir hier?
Während die VM erzeugt wird, lesen wir uns mal an
Durch, um was es geht
Sas-ka-ton
Sus
Counting IPs
Okay
Diepel
Wir übersetzen es jetzt einfach wirklich jedes Mal
Also, folgendes
Was ist die Aufgabe?
Es gibt
Eine Web-Server-Zugriffs-Protokoll-Datei
Alles klar
Unter home-admin-access.log
Die Datei
Die Datei besteht aus einer Zeile pro HTTP-Anfrage
Wobei die IP-Adresse des Anfragenden am Anfang jeder Zeile steht
Finden Sie die IP-Adresse mit den meisten Anfragen
In dieser Datei heraus
Es gibt keinen Gleichstand
Die IP-Adresse ist eindeutig
Schreiben Sie die Lösung in eine Datei
Home heißt IP
Okay, easy
Easy
Machen wir das doch mal
Probieren wir uns mal hier das Lösungsding
Ah, okay
Man kann auch einen Hash-Wert machen und gucken, ob das alles stimmt
Alles klar, gucken wir mal
Schauen wir uns das Ganze mal an
Leute, ich schiebe das einfach auf die linke Seite des Terminals
Weil da kann der Chat nicht drüber sein
Ob der Chat hier drüber ist, ist ja nicht schlimm
Alles klar
Okay, also, gehen wir mal home-admin
Wobei, da sind wir wahrscheinlich schon
Home-admin
Und da gibt es eine Access-Log
Okay, die Datei ist leer
Heißt IP.tm
Es gibt eine Access-Log, tatsächlich
Access-Log
Okay
Gucken wir doch mal kurz rein
Boah, die ist ein bisschen
Die ist ein bisschen größer
Okay, das erste in jeder Zeile ist die IP
So, und wir sollen jetzt quasi
Was sollen wir
Da wollte ich jetzt nicht hin
Hm
Was sollen wir machen?
Wir sollen zählen, welche IP
Das die meisten Requests gemacht hat
Okay, also
Ich würde sagen
Jetzt weiß ich, jetzt kommt bestimmt der erste
Useless use of cat oder irgendwie sowas
Also ganz am Anfang jeder Zeile steht die IP
Oh, ich hätte das nicht ketten sollen, das Ding
Also, sagen wir mal
Cat
An einem Leerzeichen
Field 1
So, haben wir alle IPs
Sortieren wir die IPs
So
Uniken die IPs
Ne, nicht Unik
Ähm
Unik count, geht das irgendwie?
Ich glaube schon, ich glaube Unik kann zählen
Count
Äh, Prefix
Okay, also Unik count
Okay
Jetzt haben wir pro Zeile, wie oft die Sache aufgetaucht ist
Das heißt, jetzt können wir das Ganze nochmal sortieren
Numeric
Und dann haben wir diese IP
Diese IP hat 482 Anfragen
Können wir auch
Können wir auch überprüfen
Den wir einfach sagen
Echo
Und dann was?
Char
Sum
EF42
Okay, check my solution
Ach, Moment
Ich noob
Ähm
Ich muss jetzt
Ich muss es ja erst noch in die Datei reinschreiben
Jasper, danke für den Sub
Check my solution
Ist korrekt
Wir gucken uns jetzt an, was wir hier haben
Wir gucken uns jetzt mal an, wie die offizielle Lösung dazu ist
Also, was der sagt, wie man das machen soll
To get the first field IP of
Okay, der macht es mit AWK
Cut, genau
Also, okay, aber andere Delimiter
Aber es ist im Prinzip das gleiche
Ähm, klar, mit AWK ist die schönere Variante
Weil dann ist es egal, ob es Leerzeichen oder Tabs oder sonst was sind
And pick the first field
Okay, cat access
Ja, das braucht man gar nicht
Ah, nee, ach, field 1
Okay, ja, das ist gut, das ist gut
Okay, ja, das habe ich ja auch so gemacht
You may want to append a pipe, head or tail as you consider
Und weiter, das ist ja noch nicht die Lösung
After the previous step
Sort, ja, haben wir auch gemacht
Unique minus C
Haben wir auch gemacht
Ah, der macht es anders
Ah, okay, wie macht der das?
Ich habe Sort Numeric gemacht
Und er hat
Sort minus E
Okay, das wird wahrscheinlich auch funktionieren
Das ist ja, Leute, viele Wege führen zum Ziel
Aber wir haben das Richtige rausgekriegt
Easy
Sudo, power off
Also, ich gehe davon aus, dass die Dinger noch ein bisschen schwerer werden
Das soll easy sein, ja
Das ist doch auch easy
Also, jeder, der schon ein bisschen Linux-Erfahrung
Also, ich rede jetzt nicht Linux-Desktop-Erfahrung
Reine Anwender
Aber jeder, der ein bisschen Linux-Administration-Erfahrung hatte
Sollte sowas eigentlich easy hinkriegen
Chat, findet ihr das nicht?
Okay, okay, wir machen eine Umfrage
Modge, Max, falls du noch da bist
Könntest du eine Umfrage machen?
War das easy? Ja, nein
Und ohne mit Kekse-Worten und sowas
Warum kommt nach dem S?
Was?
Was kommt nach dem S?
Okay, also, war es Eats oder nicht Eats?
Cut ein Sort, ja, kann ich dir gleich erklären
Vielleicht lasse ich ja vom Teil nur ein Highlight schneiden
Für YouTube von diesem Stream
Da könnt ihr jetzt einmal alle Hallo YouTube spammen
Wobei, ich glaube, YouTube interessiert das nicht null
Nicht die Bohne, ob ich irgendwie Linux
Admin-Challenges hier mache
Okay, also, wir sind uns nicht ganz einig
Ob es Eats oder nicht Eats ist
Aber der überwiegende Teil meint Eats
Allerdings ist es sehr knapp Eats
Und jetzt höre ich auf
Weil ich weiß genau
Alle Leute, die jetzt noch nicht abgestimmt haben
Und noch abstimmen können
Die stimmen jetzt so ab
Dass es 50-50 wird am Ende
Das ist ja nicht so einfach
Das ist immer so
Das heißt, man darf eigentlich
Sobald man im Stream das Ergebnis zeigt
Muss die Abstimmung fertig sein
Oder du musst es ignorieren
Weil genau sonst passiert nämlich exakt das
Also 50-50
Mit Google hättet ihr es auf jeden Fall alle hinbekommen
Warum? Die Frage war
Warum nach dem Cut ein Sort muss?
Weil Unix sonst nicht funktioniert
Unix erwartet, dass der Input sortiert ist
Also du musst zuerst
Also guck mal
Wenn du das hier machst
Also der erste Teil ist
Du holst dir die IP-Adressen raus
Der nächste Teil ist
Du sortierst die IP-Adressen
Du guckst
Mit Unix
Wie oft welche IP-Adresse vorkommt
Und dann
Das ist ein bisschen abweichend von der offiziellen Lösung
Dann sortiere ich das ganze nochmal numerisch
Weil nach dem hier steht ja vorne
Ganz am Anfang eine Zahl
Und mit sort-n
Sortiert er quasi anhand von
Numerisch das ganze
Und dementsprechend steht 482 unten
Und die letzte Zeile ist
Also meine Lösung ist ein bisschen anders
Als die offizielle Lösung
Aber funktioniert ja auch genauso
Google ist ja auch erlaubt
Google ist ja hier denke ich auch erlaubt
Ok Power-Off
Easy, next
More Scenarios
Also wenn ihr was wissen wollt Leute
Gerade wenn wir durch sind
Könntest du auch sort-u machen
Wahrscheinlich
In der offiziellen Lösung ist es ein revert sort
Und sowas
Wahrscheinlich könntest du auch noch ganz trickreichere Sachen machen
Der Python Crack
Hätts wahrscheinlich in Python Interpreter
Gepiped
Und das darin irgendwie sortiert
Oder was auch immer
Nutzt du deine Linux Maschine als VM
Und was für ein Linux Distro benutzt du
Das ist ne VM, korrekt
Guck da, VM
Ich benutze selbstverständlich Arch Linux
By the way
Das ist aber gut das du es ansprichst
Weil ich denke ich hätte euch das heute schon nochmal erzählen müssen
Dass ich Arch Linux verwende
Also hier nochmal ganz offiziell Leute
Ich verwende Arch Linux
Ich hoffe ihr habt das mitbekommen
Arch Linux
Nicht elitär genug für Gento
Nee auf Gento hab ich keinen Bock
Manjaro doch
Manjaro war es vorher
OpenSUSE
Oder Gentoo wie es manche sagen
Womit sollte man
Bei
Windows 11 Virtualisieren
Um halbwegs performant zu sein
Vor allem bei Workstation finde ich es
Die beste Desktop Virtualisierung
Die es gibt
Mit Webshots und allem dabei
Und bisschen 3D Beschleunigung
Und Acceleration
Und du kannst sogar nested Virtualisierung machen
Und sowas
Ja also gerade wenn wir mit so einer Übung durch sind
Und ihr was wissen wollt Leute
Könnt ihr das ohne Probleme dann
Ihr könnt es vorher schon in den Chat schreiben
Aber wenn wir mit der Übung durch sind
Kann ich ja noch ein bisschen was erklären
Wenn es noch was offene Fragen gibt
Wobei ich denke das war jetzt relativ einfach
Okay weiter
Secret Combination
Auch easy
Aber jetzt haben wir 15 Minuten Zeit
Deine Meinung zu Postgres
Beste Datenbank
Also gerade beste Open Source Datenbank
Das gute an Postgres ist
Das Postgres alles kann
Du kannst Timeseries Daten
Du kannst Timeseries Sachen drinnen speichern
Mit Timescale DB
Oh was war Timescale
Ja doch ich glaube Timescale DB
Vielleicht nicht so gut wie ein Influx
Aber performant genug
Also wenn ich jetzt mal ein paar Gramm suche
Für Wildcards und Autocomplete
Und sowas
Postgres ist das beste was es gibt
SQlite ist auch das beste was es gibt
In seinem Bereich
SQlite
Also wenn ich die Auswahl hätte zwischen
Was ist die beste universellste einsetzbare Datenbank
Dann SQlite
Weil ich glaube SQlite dürfte auch die weltweit
Verbreitetste Datenbank sein
Gerade weil so gut wie jede Android App
Mit einer internen SQlite Datenbank
Daher kommt
Das war jetzt ja nicht die Frage
Also es ging ja um
Keine
So Embedded Datenbank Gramm
Wie SQlite sondern es ging ja um
Einen richtigen Datenbank Server
Und da finde ich Postgres das beste
Auch wenn ich nicht ein super Datenbank Checker bin
Ich habe schon gelesen es gibt manchmal
Datenbank
Also manche dieser Aufgaben
Sind so Datenbank Aufgaben
Da bin ich mal gespannt
Auf gehts
Nächste Übung
Okay easy
Santiago
Find a secret combination
Okay Alice
Alice
Hat zwei geheime
Nummern versteckt auf dem System
So wir sollen
Die Anzahl der Zeilen
Rausbekommen
Wie oft
Der String Alice vorkommt
In allen TXT Files
Im Home Admin Directory
Okay
Also wir sind
DeepL ihr habt Recht
Massive
Massive DeepL
DeepL
So
Also
Alice die Spionin hat eine geheime
Zahlenkombination versteckt
Finden sie mit diesen
Finde sie mit diesen Anweisungen
So finde die Anzahl der Zeilen in denen
Alice in allen TXT Dateien im Verzeichnis
Home Admin vorkommt
Es gibt eine Datei in der Alice
Genau einmal vorkommt
In der Zeile nach diesem
Vorkommen steht eine Zahl
Schreiben sie beide Zahlen nacheinander
Als eine
Keine neue Zeile
Oder Leerzeichen
In die Lösungsdatei
Okay da hat DeepL jetzt ein bisschen
Verkackt zum Beispiel wenn die ersten
Zahlen okay
Beide Zeilen ohne
Ohne Leerzeichen ist okay
Kann man so machen
Könnt ihr auch einfach hintereinander Echonen
In Echo schreiben
Okay ähm dann probieren wir das doch mal
Also wir sollen
Rausfinden wie oft
Kommt
Alice vor
Na das ist relativ easy
Grab minus C
Alice
Wohlgemerkt Groß- und Kleinschreibung ist an der Stelle wichtig
Also machen wir nicht minus I
Und dann Sternchen
Punkt TXT
Und wir sehen
Okay
Mit AWK könntest du es bestimmt auch irgendwie
Machen aber in dem Fall ist Grab
Einfacher zumal es um Zeilen geht
Okay also hier kommt
Hier kommt Alice einmal vor
In 13420
Punkt TXT
Und in den anderen
Kommt es
12 und 0
Mal vor okay das heißt wir
Rechnen das mal kurz zusammen
Echo 398
Plus 1
Plus 12
Nach BC
Cringe
BC nicht installiert
Darf man Sachen nachinstallieren
Wahrscheinlich nicht
Glaube nicht das es funktioniert
Ah
Ne
Nachinstalliert werden darf nicht
Na gut
Ich wollte gerade sagen da machen wir es mit Bash Build
Das kommt funktioniert auch
So
Okay 411 ist schon mal
Unsere erste Zahl
Und die zweite Zahl finden
Wir in der Datei wo Alice nur
Einmal vorkommt
Könnte man eventuell mit WC rechnen
Ja
Du könntest es auch mit WC machen
Das zeige ich gleich
So machen wir das mal auf
Suchen da drin nach Alice
Kommt ja nur einmal drin vor und dann brauchen wir
In the line after
Also nach Alice
Also brauchen wir 5
Also haben wir 411
156 und das soll exakt so
In die Datei rein
Ich zeige gleich wie man es mit WC
Eventuell machen könnte
Bin mir gerade nicht ganz sicher ob es funktioniert
Müsste gehen
Und das muss jetzt in die Datei
Solution
X solution
MD5 Sum
Solution
Ja
D80E02D
Sieht gut aus check my solution
Also was man auch machen könnte
Wahrscheinlich ist
Anstatt Scrap-C
Könnte man
Wahrscheinlich auch
WC-L machen
Dann hat man auch 411
Das ist eine gute Idee
Ja
Zählt WC auch richtig wenn Alice 2 mal pro Zeile
Kommt ja
Weil Scrap das nur einmal ausspucken würde
Das ist eine gute Idee Chat das so zu machen
Was der Unterschied ist
Der Unterschied ist hier wird es angehängt
Und hier wird es überschrieben
Guck mal jetzt
Steht es zweimal drinnen
Und mehrfach
Wobei das bei ZSH nicht unbedingt
So standardmäßig funktioniert
Überschreibt das
Also das ist reinschreiben in die Datei
Aber quasi von vorne anfangen
Und den Rest überschreiben
Die Datei quasi leeren
Und dann überschreiben
Und das andere ist anhängen
Also 2 sind anhängen
1 ist reinschreiben
Also wenn du Log-File hast
Was permanent gefüllt werden soll
Dann ist das
Wenn du den Log hast pro Script ran
Zum Beispiel
Dann würdest du es mit einem machen
Was macht minus L
Zählen
Für Lines
Zeilen zählen
Dann zeigst du dir auch Zeilen
Das zeigt dir Zeilen, Charakter
Und keine Ahnung
Was sonst noch an
Wörter, Charakter, Zeilen
Irgendwie sowas
WC-L ist nur Zeilen
Nur Zeilen rechnen
WC-L ist auch das
Am häufigsten benutzte
In der Kombination
Ok, Sudo, Power-Off, Easy
Bevor ich ausmache
Noch irgendwelche
Questions
Zu der Aufgabe
Ich vermute mal jetzt wird es ein bisschen schwerer
Aber ja, wir gucken uns doch mal
Die offizielle Lösung an
Was die dazu schreiben
Use Find
Ok, das haben wir schon mal nicht gemacht
Use Find and pass the results to Grab via X-Arc
Kann man auch machen
Solution, Example
Find, Home, Admin, Type
Ok, die TXT
X-Arcs, Grab, minus T
Ja, ok
Es sind Einzeiler
Könnte man auch machen
Ok, leuchtet mir ein
Könnte man auch so machen
Ja
Also was X-Arcs macht ist folgendes
X-Arcs nimmt die Zeilen
Vom Input
Und macht daraus quasi eine Argumentliste
Die sie an Grab anhängt
Was im Endeffekt bedeutet
Wir rufen den Grab auf
Und dahinter schreibt es die Dateien
So das Grab in den Dateien
Aber wie gesagt, man kann auch Sternchen.txt machen
Ok, fertig
Was ist Z-Server
Z-Server ist
Troubleshoot and make
Z-Servers happy
Leadcode for Linux
Capture the flag challenges
Train and prove your debugging skills
Practice for your next
SRE DevOps interview
Also im Endeffekt bekommst du den
Linux Server bei AWS
Auf dem du verschiedene Aufgaben lösen musst
Das war doch nicht die ganze Solution
Doch
Also das was ich gemacht habe
Science
Science auch oder?
Science funktioniert auch hier
Wobei ich meins angenehmer fand
Das ist ohne Registrierung
Aber das hat ein Limit
Also du kannst jetzt nicht
Irgendwie das ganze 40 mal am Tag machen
Oder so
Achso der zweite Teil hat noch gefehlt
Ja jetzt steht stimmt
Alles klar
Nice haben wir
Sudo Power of
Bam
Next
More Scenarios
Also Leute
Easy ist jetzt fertig
Jetzt wird es anstrengend
Jetzt kommt die Medium
Dinger
Manhattan
Into Database
Wollen wir mal gucken
Was Manhattan für Probleme hat
Manhattan hat wahrscheinlich zu viel
Twitter Deutschland in den letzten Tagen
Gelesen
Und hat keinen Bock mehr
Dann hatte ich gedacht
Ich höre auf
Ich stelle den Dienst ein
Richtig gut da ist
Schön dass du deinen Weg her gefunden hast
Und das dir es gefällt
Also wir können uns das ganze mal durchlesen
Bis die VM gestartet ist
Ok Description
Diepel
Also Beschreibung
Ihr Ziel ist es
Eine Zeile in eine bestimmte
In eine bestehende
Postgres Datenbank einzufügen
Das Problem ist nicht spezifisch
Für Postgres
Und sie brauchen keine Details darüber zu wissen
Obwohl es hilfreich sein könnte
Ja ich habe die neuen
Api Pricings gesehen
Total lächerlich
Hilfreiche Informationen zu Postgres
Es handelt sich um einen Dienst
Der an einem Port
Lauscht
Und auf die Festplatte in ein
Datenverzeichnis schreibt
Dessen Speicherort im Parameter
Data Directory
Der Konfigurationsdatei
ETC Postgres 14 main postgres.conf
Definiert ist
In unserem Fall wird Postgres von Systemd
Als eine Unit mit dem Namen
Postgresql verwaltet
Vom Standard Admin Benutzer
Ok der Test
Das ist der Test da können wir testen ob es funktioniert
Und
Schauen wir mal
Ob der Server bereit ist
Ok führen wir das mal aus
Und stellen fest nope geht nicht
Warum geht es nicht
Weil
No such file or directory is the server running
Ok wahrscheinlich
Läuft Postgres einfach nicht
Postg
Wobei es heißt glaube ich PG
Irgendwas gibt es nicht
Ok Systemctl
Status
Postgres
Postgresql ist glaube ich
Ok das ist
Ok jetzt wird es langsam interessant
Ich hätte jetzt gedacht easy
Wir gucken einfach und das Service läuft nicht
Und wir starten den Service
So einfach ist es anscheinend schon mal nicht
Also Postgres selber läuft wohl
Aber trotzdem funktioniert der Zugriff
Auf Postgres nicht
Das heißt wir machen jetzt mal netstat
Und gucken ob an Port 5
5 4 3 2
Überhaupt was lauscht
Und wir stellen fest
Postgres ist der Meinung das es läuft
Ja das ist komisch
Ok
Das ist natürlich merkwürdig
Postgres ist der Meinung das es läuft
Aber
Postgres
Läuft anscheinend gar nicht
Nice Chainlore
Werde ich meinem Cutter ausrichten
Wir werden in Zukunft easy selbstverständlich
Noch als easy Emote einplänen
Und Begründung ist weil es der Chainlore gesagt hat
Aber
Wäre wahrscheinlich doch besser gewesen
Ok lasst mal kurz
So prinzipiell ein paar Sachen checken
War log
Postgres
Mainlog
Wieder ist nichts drin
Das ist schon mal sus
Could not create log file
No space
Ach die Festplatte
Ist voll
Ok Moment
Df-h
Die Festplatte ist voll
Ok
Das ist eine gute Sache
Das ist ein guter Test
Das ist gar nicht so weit
Von der Realität weg Leute
Das kommt tatsächlich vor
In der Praxis
Ok die Festplatte ist voll
Also gehen wir mal nach
Opt
PG Data
Guck mal was es da so gibt
Guck mal es gibt sogar ein File
Was sich delete me nennt
rm delete me
Ah Moment
In dem File steht überhaupt nichts drin
Der muss aber auch nur ein Pitfile anlegen
Vielleicht reicht das ja delete me
Hm
Ok
Systemctl
Restart
Postgresql
That's that
Ups WTF
Netstat
Minus
Nein die läuft immer noch nicht
Wir löschen
Komm wir löschen die anderen
Ich mein das sind Backup Files
Oder irgendwie irgendwie
Postgres dumps oder sowas
Das hier wird ja
Das hier ist ja die eigentliche Datenbank
Wir löschen den ganzen Kempel hier einfach mal
rm
File
m
So
Restart Postgres
Hast du das neue Harry Potter Spiel
Ne hab ich nicht
Ich war aber nach diesem ganzen Circle Jerk
Auf Twitter
Mal ganz kurz haben überlegen ob ich es mir nicht kaufen soll
Einfach um ein paar Leute abzufacken
Aber ich hab mir dann am Ende gedacht
Ne eigentlich ist es bescheuert Geld auszugeben
Für ein Game was dich nicht interessiert
Und dich das Franchise auch nicht wirklich interessiert
Also insofern
So Netstat
Jetzt läuft die Datenbank
Sudo
Insert into
Funktioniert Datenbank läuft wieder
Check my solution ist korrekt
You made a Zetkes Server happy
Congrats
Nice oder
Wir sind schon richtig
Richtig
Nette Leute hier
Server is happy
White people happy server
Ich muss jetzt auf Twitter streamen
Ich muss gar nix
Alles auf Twitter streamen
Das machen bestimmt manche Leute
Zum Ultratriggern
Poggas Server ist wieder glücklich
Chat gibts noch Fragen dazu
Wollt ihr noch was wissen
Hab ich irgendwas übersehen
Ja man kann
Man kann auf Twitter
Früher war das mit Periscope
Aber man kann auf Twitter irgendwie streamen
Kannste auf Twitter so viel Bullshit machen
Was keiner will
Ach was wäre die Originallösung gewesen
Gute Frage gucken wir gleich
Ey Diskspace voll
Wir hatten Glück das in der Fehlermeldung
Stand no space left on device
Weil auf die Idee da jetzt zu gucken
Wär ich wahrscheinlich erst viel später gekommen
Die Originallösung
Ja was ist die Originallösung
Run the test
Is this Postgres Server running
You can check sudo c
Das haben wir gemacht
PSAux Postgres
Doch haben wir glaube ich auch sowas probiert
System start Postgres
Check status again
Sowas in der Richtung haben wir auch gemacht
Das haben wir nicht gemacht
Minus u Postgres blablub
Wir haben es im Postgres Log selber gefunden
Ist aber auch ok
Ist egal wo man es herfindet
Warlogsyslog
Hab ich auch nicht reingeguckt
Ich habe im Postgres Log selber geguckt
Check Diskspace
Das haben wir wieder gemacht
Minus h ist übrigens nicht wirklich erforderlich
Minus h ist nur das es human readable ist
Das heißt das ist
Hier hätten wir es auch gesehen
Aber minus h ist natürlich deutlich angenehmer zu lesen
Weil ähm
Was weiß ich wie viele Bytes
Versus ähm
8g
Da erkennt man es deutlich besser
So und danach
Cap minus i im syslog
Aha
Und dann Postgres Data
Ok Leute
Ich habe es ganz anders gemacht
Anscheinend
Delete Backup Files
Ok das habe ich dann wiederum gemacht
Und das Ding gestartet
Ok die offizielle Lösung ist finde ich fast komplett
Komplizierter als meins
Leute das ist jetzt
Das ist wirklich noch nichts großartig kompliziertes
Ich habe 15 Jahre Linux Erfahrung
Und auch Admin Erfahrung
Da ist sowas nicht sonderlich kompliziert
Ich gebe zu
Das war Zufall
Das muss ich auch zugeben
Das war in dem Fall tatsächlich Zufall
Das ich das gefunden habe so schnell
Das es so direkt im Log drinne stand
Das war Zufall
Das hätte durchaus länger dauern können
Man muss sich da keine Gedanken drüber machen
Ich benutze täglich Linux
NCDU ist wahrscheinlich nicht drauf
Ich benutze täglich Linux auf der Arbeit
Sowohl auf dem Desktop als auch
In unserer gesamten Linux Umgebung
So ein paar Sachen
Wie Dienst läuft nicht
Log Files nachgucken
Das macht man so oft da denkt man gar nicht mal
Großartig drüber nach
Ich habe in Warlock geschaut genau
Das ist auch nicht verkehrt erstmal zu gucken
Also ich glaube so eines der meist
Benutzten Befehle ist
df-h, free-m
Und solche Geschichten
Danach dicht gefolgt von htop
Okay vielleicht normales top
Wenn es kein htop gibt
Alles klar check my solution
Korrekt
Bam
Sudo? Ne brauchen wir nicht
Power off
Gibt es noch Fragen zu der Aufgabe Chat?
Ist das eine Debian4M
Das ist eine gute Frage
Gucken wir mal
Alter leckt
Meine Güte jetzt haben wir
Ach home is not set
Äh cat etc
Das ist ein Debian
GNU Linux
Nicht das man etwa auf die Idee kommt
Einfach nur Linux zu sagen
Weil ihr wisst was passiert
Das dann wirds
Dann wirds kritisch
Wenn man einfach nur Linux sagt
Man muss schon korrekterweise GNU Linux sagen
Sonst spawnt er bei euch um die Ecke
Und flamed euch
Du hast keinen inneren Zugang von dort
Du kannst dort nicht rein und nicht raus
Funktioniert nicht
Auf der Kiste
Die haben das schon ganz gut gemacht
Guck du kannst jetzt zum Beispiel
Du kannst doch nicht mal einen DNS Server pingen
Kannst gar nichts machen
Was aber auch sinnvoll ist
Weil sonst würden die Leute garantiert
Das irgendwie missbrauchen
Was für ein Linux
Wird auf Enterprise Ebene gerne benutzt
Dazu kann man eigentlich bloß sagen
Was es ja nicht mehr gibt
In der jetzigen Form
Zum größten Teil Red Hat
Mit UFW geblockt
Äh
Ach gehört mal installiert
Ne ne das ist bestimmt nicht geblockt
Das ist ein privates Netz ohne Zugang
So blöd ist der Betreiber bestimmt nicht
Also Red Hat
Red Hat ist im Enterprise Umfeld
Eigentlich mit Abstand das beliebteste
Zumindest meiner Erfahrung nach
IP Tables willst du
Ja können wir auch gucken
V minus L
Ansonsten
Ich wollte gerade sagen
In Azure ist Ubuntu tatsächlich
Relativ beliebt
Dadurch das es jetzt kein
CentOS mehr gibt
Könnte ich mir vorstellen
Das es im Enterprise Umfeld
Auch etwas nachlässt
Weil aktuell ist es so
Entweder du kaufst dir wirklich Red Hat
Für jede Kiste
Bzw. mit Support Abo und Geschiss
Oder du benutzt
Eines der neuen CentOS Nachfolge Projekte
Genau sowas
Wobei da hat kaum noch
Eine Erfahrung so wirklich damit
Oder oder
Das ist auch eine Möglichkeit
Oder man benutzt Oracle Linux
Kann man auch machen
Wobei ich persönlich eher auf Ubuntu setzen würde
Debian ist auch möglich
Also
So wie Shryker sagt
Es ist eigentlich
Red Hat Ubuntu nicht
Debian
Suse ist mir ehrlich gesagt
In freier Wildbahn
Bis einmal für die Telefonanlage
Noch nie untergekommen
Ja Alpine wenn die Container zählen
Da hast du recht
OpenBSD habe ich so
Ich überlege gerade
Habe ich so in freier Wildbahn
Einmal ein OpenBSD gesehen
Ne ich glaube nicht
Doch habe ich
PFSense habe ich ein paar mal im Einsatz gesehen
Aber ansonsten
Das haben den Vorteil
Die sind halt sehr klein
Ok also sind wir hier fertig
Sudo Power Off
So
More Scenarios
Next please
Wo sind wir stehen geblieben
Manhattan
Can't write into database
Als nächstes kommt Tokio
Can't serve Webfile
Medium 15 Minuten
Ok Run
Ist erstmal relativ
Kurz und knapp
Also Stufe Mittel
Es gibt einen Webserver
Der eine Datei war www.html
Ok das ist also der Standard
Der eine Datei war
www.htmlindex.html
Mit dem Inhalt
Hello Set Server
Bereitstellt
Aber wenn wir versuchen sie lokal
Mit einem http Client wie curl
Zu überprüfen
Wird nichts zurückgegeben
In diesem Szenario
Geht es nicht um die spezielle
Webserver Konfiguration
Und sie müssen nur
Allgemeine Kenntnisse
Über die Funktionsweise von Webservern haben
Ok Test ist
Curl auf port 80
Sollte Hello Set Server
Zurückliefern
Alles klar
Gucken wir mal was passiert wenn wir es ausführen
Curl hängt
Hängen
Ist komisch
Home
Ubuntu
Ähm
Netstat
Wir gucken mal ob auf port 80 überhaupt
Das läuft
Port 80 läuft ein Apache
Hm
Der läuft
Und ist an
Ob IPv6 auf port 4
Das ist bei lokalen Sachen
Egal das müsste auch so funktionieren
Ok ich habe eine Idee
Ich habe eine Idee
Nachdem das hier gar nicht funktioniert
Machen wir mal Systemctl
Stopp Apache
Äh
Apache 2
Ok Apache 2 ist es
Status
Aus
Wir haben das gleiche
Ergebnis wie vorher
Passt mal auf Leute
Die wollen uns T-baiten
Ich sag euch
Sieht gut aus
Ne sieht nicht gut aus
Die wollen uns ernsthaft T-baiten
Ich habe es eigentlich nur eingegeben
Weil vor 2 Minuten
Jemand im Chat geschrieben hat
Wie man mit IP Tables
Überhaupt die
Chains und so auflistet
Ich habe das aus dem Kopf gar nicht gewusst
Also ohne den Chat hätte ich das nicht so schnell raus gekickt
Ja daran liegt es
Da dran liegt es
Da droppt einfach alles
Also normalerweise hätte jetzt nicht einer im Chat geschrieben hätte ich folgendes gemacht
Ich hätte einen temporären Webserver
Oder netcat gestartet
Auf port 80
Ich hätte Apache ausgeschaltet
Wir machen das mal
Wir tun mal so als hätten wir es noch nicht gefunden
Also wahrscheinlich hätte ich als nächstes folgendes gemacht
Wahrscheinlich hätte ich das hier gemacht
Wahrscheinlich hätte ich sowas hier gemacht
Haben wir eine T-Max drauf?
Ah Polgar ist nice
Also wahrscheinlich hätte ich jetzt gesagt
War www
Alter
Schluck der
War www
Hätte ich mal hier geguckt
Okay es ist zwar alles root
Das ist schon sehr merkwürdig aber es ist zumindest lesbar
Und dann hätte ich wahrscheinlich sowas hier gemacht
Port 80
Ach Mist okay
Ist gar nicht drauf
Ja dann
Ah ne doch ist drauf
Wahrscheinlich hätte ich das hier gemacht
Und dann hätte ich mal probiert
Curl localhost 80
Braucht man ja eigentlich
Und es geht immer noch nicht
Und dann wäre ich wahrscheinlich schon skeptisch geworden
Weil ich mir gedacht habe okay
Das kommt gar nichts an
Das nächste was ich wahrscheinlich probiert hätte
Ist auf Port 8000
Und dann hätte ich geguckt geht es auf Port 8000
Auf Port 8000 funktioniert es
Und dann hätte ich mir gedacht
Moment
Woran kann das liegen
Und dann hätte ich wahrscheinlich IP Tables geguckt
IP Tables
Minus V minus L
Und da ist es drinne
Ja okay also dann
Dann wählen wir das ganze mal
System CTL
Restart Apache
IP Tables
Boah das weiß ich aus dem Kopf nicht
IP Tables minus D
Keine Ahnung
Weiß ich aus dem Kopf nicht
IP Tables delete
Rule
Ist NF Tables
Ist NF Tables eigentlich mittlerweile weit verbreitet
Nö
IP Tables minus F
Okay
Wie löscht man
Okay ich machs einfach wie
Ich machs einfach wie der Chat das schreibt
IP Tables einfach nur minus F
Oder sowas wie minus F input
Das ist doch glaub ich ne Input Regel
Gibt sowas wie IP Tables
IP Tables minus F
Input sowas
No chain ah ne
Input groß geschrieben so
Okay einfach nur minus F
Alles klar
Okay jetzt ist leer
Curl localhost
Oh
Da ist noch mehr im Argin
Ne Leute das hab ich jetzt kaputt gemacht
Ich glaube das hab ich mit meinem Python Zeug kaputt gemacht
Ne
Apache ist gestartet
Alter was will denn das hier
Netstat minus
Tulpen
Apache läuft
Ich glaube ich habs kaputt gemacht
Aber Curl funktioniert nicht warum
Aber was ist der Test
Achso Moment
You don't have permissions
Eigentlich müsste das ja auch
WWW Data gehören
War schon kaputt
Also normalerweise
Müsste das WWW Data gehören
Vermute ich mal
Gucken wir mal
PSAugs Crap Apache
Der läuft als WWW Data
Allerdings wundert es mich
Weil
Es ist read
Was im Endeffekt
Ah
She bladed
Deswegen funktioniert das nicht
Okay dann machen wir es gleich mal richtig
C-hown WWW Data
WWW Data
C-hown minus R
HTML
Curl
Jetzt funktioniert es
Okay alles klar
Das hab ich doch nicht selbst kaputt gemacht
Also waren es zwei
Schritte
Als erstes musste man feststellen
Das IP Tables
HTTP Traffic blockt
Und als zweites
Hat man festgestellt die Datei hat die falsche Rechte
Okay schauen wir mal
Ob das jetzt funktioniert
Check my solution
Also dann schauen wir uns mal
Die offizielle Lösung an Chat
Wenn ihr Fragen zu dieser Übung habt
Hauts jetzt in den Chat
Wahrscheinlich habe ich manche Sachen übersehen
Oh ich glaube wir haben länger gebraucht
Als notwendig
Dafür ist
Okay alles klar
Also Solution
Run Test Curl
Okay haben wir gemacht
Siehste da wäre ich wahrscheinlich erst viel später drauf gekommen
IP Tables zu gucken
Siehste das war Zufall
Weil es eben jemand im Chat vorher geschrieben hat
IP Tables
Dann muss man IP Tables minus F machen
Okay
Dann muss man das Ownership checken
Und dann chown
Okay ich habe recursive chown gemacht
Alles klar
Okay nice
Haben wir auch ausgekriegt
Pyfet
Wobei das wahrscheinlich gar nicht funktioniert
Weil der DNS ist ja cached
Kannst du eine Anfrage schicken
Ja sowas in der Richtung machen wir
Okay gibt anscheinend
Ne habe ich nicht
Das hätte
Da lagst du gar nicht so falsch mit
War es ja am Ende dann auch
Also was
Okay Moment
Hallo und guten Tag
Ich habe mal eine Frage
Vielleicht kann mir hier einer helfen
Ich benutze in meiner Schule auf
Eine Linux Vm Tools
Was
Ich benutze in meiner Schule auf Linux Vm Tools
Kann ich meine erstellte Sendbox
Die Daten kopieren und diese bei mir zu Hause auf Windows aufrufen
Mit dem Vm Tools
Ich habe keine Ahnung was du genau machst
Da kann ich jetzt so nichts zu sagen
Das ist mir zu vage
Ist das fertig
Next
Tokio sind wir stehen geblieben
Tokio
Als nächstes kommt Capetown
Borked Nginx
Das hört sich ja schon an
Run
You have full root access
Also Moment das gehört ja gar nicht dazu
Okay also
Was ist die Aufgabe
Gestörter Nginx
Kollege vom Chainlord der Nginx hier
Der von System D
Verwaltet wird
Wenn sie curl-l machen
Ausführen
Erhalten sie curl
Failed to connect to local host
Beheben sie das so dass
Sie die Standard Nginx
Seite erhalten wenn sie curl ausführen
Okay
Okay die Vm ist noch nicht
Ready
Nicht ready
Ich glaube er will einfach nur seine
Vm kopieren ja vielleicht
Keine Ahnung
Er könnte sich auch die Dateien auf
Den USB Stick kopieren und dann bei sich daheim
In der Vm oder
Was auch immer ich kann da draus das nicht erkennen
Also du kannst die also wenn du die
Die Vm kopierst komplett
Also mit Config Files und Disk Images
Und sowas da kannst du die ohne Probleme
1 zu 1 auf dem anderen Rechner starten
Okay was
In der Schule haben wir ein Linux PC
Da ist Vm Tools drauf da machten wir
Ein Windows 10 pro Send Box
Drinnen jetzt habe ich aber
Also kein Linux sondern nur
Windows 10 kann ich nicht erteilen die ich
Achso
Ja sind ja die gleiche es ist ja
Das gleiche Betriebssystem in der Vm
Jaja das funktioniert
Ne also ich kenne das
Aber dieses habe ich nicht gemacht
Das funktioniert am besten ist du nimmst
Den USB Stick ziehst du das da drauf und nimmst es dann einfach mit
Okay also
Wo sind wir stehen geblieben Open Terminal
So was soll funktionieren
Was soll funktionieren
Erstmal root werden wie immer
Curl
127.0.1
Geht nicht Connection Refused
Der ist in Nginx Web Server
Installed
Okay
Also System
CTL Status Nginx
Failed
Monk HS
Geht schon gut los
Warum ist der Nginx Server
Warum Failed der
Der Failed weil
Unexpected
In ETC Nginx
Sites Enabled Default
Aha
Da sind irgendwelche Zeichen drin
Die da nicht rein sollen
Ehm
Ich sehe es nicht
Wo ist da
Er sagt Zeile 1
Ah
She baited
Hab ich nicht gesehen
Leute
You got you baited
You got you got you baited
Alles klar
Okay so Semikolon weg
Restart
Nginx
Okay das sieht jetzt schon viel besser aus
Das wird aber wahrscheinlich nicht alles gewesen sein oder
Status Nginx Running
Eats
Okay das wird aber wirklich
Ich glaube nicht das das alles gewesen wird
Internal
Okay ich wusste doch das da was kommt
Internal Server Error
Moment
Jetzt müssen wir nochmal
Awww
Vielleicht heißt die Datei falsch
Okay ich mein sie gehört root
Aber sie hat read access das sollte reichen
Da ist doch bestimmt ein Schreibfehler drin
Oder sowas
Index Nginx
Nibian.html
Darf das
Darf das Ding so heißen
Das darf so heißen okay
MV
Wir verschieben das Ding jetzt mal
Machen einen Curl und gucken was rauskommt
Pop in
Okay also prinzipiell
Geht das
Aber es hat einen Internal Server
Hä
Da kaputt
Wie kommt man auf einen Internal
Festplatte voll wieder
Wie kommt man auf einen Internal Server Error
Bei einer einfachen Log Datei
Äh bei einer einfachen HTML Datei
Benutzerrechte scheinen okay zu sein
Okay guck mal mal Wahl Log
Show Indie HTML
Können wir gleich machen na klar
Alter Windows was jetzt los
Nginx
Error Log
Oh oh was ist da was ist da los
Tmax
Ach fuck
Okay ist kein Tmax auf
Open Files
Two
Hat das Ding irgendwelche Limits gesetzt
Dass es keine Dateien aufmachen kann
Das ist
Hat das ein File Handle Limit
Irgendwo gesetzt
Was ich jetzt nicht gesehen hab
Wobei man das wahrscheinlich nicht in der
Okay das ist jetzt tatsächlich ein bisschen komplizierter
Ich glaub hier in der
Config setzt man das nicht
Moment Moment Moment
Google
Too many open files Nginx
Aha Aha
Too many open files
Also in der Nginx Config hab ich nix gesehen
Es wär aber auch bescheuert
Ah hier guck mal
Limits
Das kann sein das in der Limits Datei was drinnen steht
Nope
Du hast recht im Unit File
Im Unit File könnte wirklich sein
Systemctl edit
Okay
Stack Overflow driven bug fixing
Limit file
Ich hab seriously keine Ahnung was diese Option macht
Ich habe diese Option
Noch nie in meinem Leben verwendet
Du hast 2 war www
Nee ich kann keine 2 war www haben
Okay wir schreiben einfach
10.000 rein oder so
Okay easy
Wenn das hilft
Ups
Oh Bäm
Ah das ist ja Nano MonkaS
Wer macht denn sowas
Wer quält einen hier mit Nano Mensch
Richtiger Pepega Editor
Systemctl
Restart
Nginx
Wie was
Hä die Datei haben wir doch vorhin
Editiert
Ach etc Nginx
Ist es da auch noch verkehrt
Oder was
Ach
Kann man sich mit der ID
Etwa verbinden
Chat
Ja okay
Ich muss die Kiste jetzt ausschalten
Leute wer weiß was ihr da drauf rumwurstet
Ähm
Das hätte ich ja nicht gedacht
Das man mit der ID
Irgendwelche komischen
Dinger anstellen kann
Das hätte ich wirklich nicht gedacht aber okay
Dann kann man das so im Stream nicht machen
Kann man ja anscheinend
Anscheinend geht das
Also es gibt jetzt 2 Varianten
Wie wir das machen können Chat
Entweder
Ihr haltet euch zurück
Wobei ich vermuten
Vermute
Das das nicht funktionieren wird
Oder ich muss das irgendwie ausblenden
Ah okay
Oder Fullscreen oder
Ne das ist auch dumm
Einfach die Katze umdrehen
Um in die Ecke
Ne ne ne so einfach ist das glaube ich nicht
Ich blende nicht und das jetzt
Kann man nicht irgendwie einfach die Adressleiste ausblenden
Oder so
Okay wir müssen das glaube ich OBS technisch
Irgendwie ein bisschen verschieben
Okay jetzt muss ich mal kurz gucken
Ob das jetzt weg ist
Ne
Oh da muss ich viel zu viel ausblenden
Ja das ist doof
Da muss uns irgendwas anderes einfallen
Kegelcheat baited
Hahaha
Ne ne das kannst du vergessen
Der Chat wird sich nicht benehmen
Das kannst du das kannst du
Das ist ausgeschlossen
Kannst den OBS einfach eine Colorsource hinzufügen
Und dann
Okay gibt es die Möglichkeit Chrome
Hide Addressbar
Auto Hide Addressbar
Okay
Ja ich muss ich muss wohl nen Overlay machen
Hide
Gibt es da irgendwas
About Flags
Hä Hide Toolbar
Ist das ganz was anderes
Ach ne das geht tatsächlich
Das geht das geht tatsächlich
Ach komm scheiß drauf
Ich mach jetzt einfach folgendes
Easy
Jetzt seht ihr auch nix mehr
Okay more Scenarios
Weil mich das triggert
Ich kann keine 1 mehr kopieren
Also wo sind wir stehen geblieben
Borked Nginx
Das hatten wir gerade
Das haben wir gefixt
Außer Kegelcheat baited
Das hätte funktioniert
Bin mir relativ sicher das hätte funktioniert
Jetzt
Ich mein wir können es auch einfach nochmal schnell fixen
Können wir nämlich gleich testen ob es funktioniert
Wir probieren es nochmal aus
Wir machen das nochmal schnell
Das dauert ja bloß 2-3 Minuten
Kegelcheat baited
Hahaha
Zu geil
15 Minuten soll die Aufgabe gehen
Ja sonst wird es für den zu teuer
Auf AWS
Kegelcheat baited
Wer das wohl gewesen ist
Warum gibt es den
Preis Champ nicht mehr
Weil es zu eklig war
Die Crawler aktuell zu halten
Ich glaube Leute
Ich glaube wir dürfen das nicht nochmal machen
Ich glaube wir dürfen es nicht nochmal machen
Die VM geht nicht auf
Kann das sein
Dass das broken ist
Wie Power aufbringt nichts
Naja
Ach jetzt dürfen wir okay
Alter
Hahaha
Okay
Das heißt wir wissen jetzt wo wir es positionieren müssen
Und zwar wir müssen es so positionieren
Okay wenn ich es jetzt schließe
Okay jetzt ist alles weg
Connection closed
Okay jetzt ist
Jetzt ist weg
Jetzt müssen wir nochmal einen Server erstellen
Wahrscheinlich sind wir gleich im Raid Limit drin
Wahrscheinlich sind wir gleich im Raid Limit
Und dürfen nicht weiter machen
Kurz Cookies clearen
Ich glaube die sind nicht so blöd
Und machen das auf Cookie Basis
Es steht unten
Wenn ich über den Link haffer
Alter es ist ja gut jetzt man
Warum ist das so kompliziert
Brauch ich unten
Brauch ich unten einen Link
Brauch ich hier unten nochmal einen Terminal drüber
Oder wie
Okay wir machen hier oben mal was anderes
Excellent
Okay
Jetzt sieht man nichts oder
Chat Top Secret
Jetzt ist
Jetzt ist alles hidden
Okay also zwei Sachen
Moment
Wenn ich das jetzt rüber schiebe
Glück gehabt Leute
Knappe Geschichte
Man sieht nichts
Wo sind wir stehen genug
ETC Engine X
Default
Wo war das Ding
Sites Enabled Default
Irgendwie so
Zack die Musik ist aus
So geht das nicht
Also hier war das drin
System CTL Restart
Engine X
Status
Was war das andere Problem nochmal
Ah das ist das
Sys Edit
Hier das da
Limit
Okay
PPGA Editor Mann
Yes
Hat das jetzt funktioniert
Restart
Engine X
Status Engine X
Läuft jetzt steht ja auch nicht Kekkelschiebe
Da drin
Und Curl Headdings Returns
Returns okay
Check my solution
Funktioniert alles klar
Also Leute
So war die offizielle
Achso wir können das mal angucken was die offizielle Lösung ist
Wie man das ganze fixen soll
Check Status of Engine X
Jo haben wir gemacht
Engine X minus T
Das hätte ich machen sollen
Habe ich nicht dran gedacht das es sowas gibt
Hat aber glaube ich jemand im Chat geschrieben
After fixing config file
And restarting Engine X
Hat 500er Error
Block gucken
Ich glaube das habe ich auch gemacht
Und dann soll man im Service
Limit no file anpassen
Und dann
Restarten
Okay alles klar haben wir gemacht
Bam
Next please
Wir sind stehen geblieben bei
Borked Engine X
Als nächstes kommt jetzt Salta
Docker container won't start
Da bin ich jetzt mal gespannt
Ok
Also was ist die Aufgabe
Die Aufgabe ist
Im Verzeichnis
Home Admin App
Befindet sich eine gedockte
Eine Dockerize
Ok
Befindet sich eine
Containery Dockerisierte
NodeJS Web Anwendung
Erstellen sie einen Docker Container
So das sie eine Web Anwendung
Auf Port
8888 erhalten
Und zu ihr Curlen können
Damit die Lösung gültig ist
Sollte es nur einen laufenden
Docker Container geben
Also der Test ist
Curl localhost
Soll Hello World zurückgeben
Schauen wir mal
Du du du du du du
Was macht Curl eigentlich
So Web Request
Curl hat bald 25 jähriges Jubiläum
Im März
Das habe ich auf GitHub gelesen
Das ist wie so ein Curl Celebration Day
Oder sowas
Im März irgendwann
Du du du du du
Ok auf gehts
Ok was passiert wenn man das hier
Ah ok da läuft
Ok gut das wir das
Ausprobiert haben am Anfang
Weil da wäre ich jetzt auf die Nase gefallen
Das der Port geblockt ist
Es läuft schon was auf Port 8888
Was läuft denn
Was läuft denn so auf Port 8888
Netstat
Minus Tulben
Es läuft auf Port 8888
Ein Engine
X
Systemctl Stop Engine X
Und jetzt machen wir nochmal einen Curl
Und jetzt geht nichts mehr
Ok das ist schon mal gut
So wo liegt die Docker Anwendung
Home
Admin App
Ich will ein bisschen was sehen hier
Ok Home Admin
Home Web
Da gibt es ein Docker File
Kann ich das hier Resizen ohne das ich es irgendwie leake
Ja kann ich
Also da liegt ein Docker File
Ein ServerJS
Gucken wir mal in ServerJS rein
Oh das ist eine Express Anwendung
Habe ich keinen Plan von
Map Slash Send Hello World
Ok alles klar
Ja gut
Tmax
Gibt es nicht
Ach toll
Dann machen wir einfach mal
Docker Build Punkt
Geben wir dem Ding mal Name App
Was ist Tmax
Da kannst du dann mehrere
Kannst du in einem Terminal mehrere Tabs und sowas aufmachen
Das ist ganz praktisch
Wenn man ein paar Sachen parallel machen möchte
So also wir haben jetzt die App gebaut
Dann machen wir jetzt mal Docker Run
Minus D
Weil ich nicht will das es im Vordergrund ist
Da ich noch was tippen kann
Minus D App
Ok
Docker PS
Oh ok
Docker
Log
Logs
Wie heißt das Ding
Kind
Achja guck mal da
Es gibt ein Fehler in der NodeJS Anwendung
Cannot find Module
User src
AppServeJS
Lasst uns mal in das Docker File
Gucken
Ok
Das soll 8.8.8.8 sein oder
Nicht 8.8.8.0
Warte mal
Moment Moment
Ich glaube die wollen uns schon wieder Cheap Baiten
Genau das heißt Server Punkt JS
Alter der Cheap
Das ist ein Master
Master Cheap Baiter
Der Path fürs Working Gear sieht falsch aus
User Source
Sicher
Nö
Müsste eigentlich stimmen
Sehen wir gleich
Ähm
Ein richtiger Master Cheap Baiter ist das
Das heißt nicht Serve Punkt JS
Server Punkt JS
Build
Run
Docker PS
Aha
Netstat
Ach ich hab Port Mapping nicht richtig gemacht
Docker Stop
Hab das Port Mapping nicht richtig gemacht
Wir wollen es ja auf Port 8.8.8.8 haben
Wir machen
Wir werden nicht das Docker File anpassen
Wir sagen einfach
Docker Run
Und dann
Minus P
8.8.8.8
Auf Port 8.8.8.0
Bam
Docker PS
Aha
Läuft
Jop
Ok
Und was ist der Test
Der Test ist Curl 8.8.8.8 Returns Hello World
Fuck
Das wäre ja auch zu einfach gewesen
Wenn das einfach funktioniert hätte
Warum funktioniert denn das nicht
Netstat
Oh ne
Es ist wieder eine IP Tables Regel
Ich raste aus
Boah das ist zu viel
Ich seh nix
Ist das was Schlimmes
Sieht doch ok aus oder
Ne was ist das hier
Ne alles gut
Ne das ist eigentlich ok
Oh what
Ne das sieht das sieht eigentlich ok aus
Ok
Warum geht das nicht
Netstat
Sieht eigentlich ok aus
Docker Stop
Die App hört auf einem anderen Port
Aber das ist nicht wild
Fuck
Ich hab
Ich hab Steuerung W gedrückt
Shit
Es war nicht so high IQ
Curl Local Host 8.8.8.8
Connection Resetted
Ok
Jetzt stehe ich echt ein bisschen auf dem Schlauch
Was hat der jetzt für Probleme
Docker Logs
Moment
Der Server startet an 8.8.8.8
Anstatt auf
Ja im Docker File
CD Home Admin
Docker File
Aha
8.8.8.8
Weil ich vermute mal im Server GS
Steht Port 8
Aha ok ok ok
Docker Stop
Da war auch noch ein Fehler drin
Alles klar
Wir haben zwar den richtigen Port umgeleitet
Aber die Anwendung lauschte auf einem anderen Port
Jetzt wirds funktionieren hier
Richtiger T-Baiter
Der Typ
So jetzt können wir quasi 8.8.8.8 extern auf 8.8.8.8 intern machen
Docker PS
Curl Local Host 8.8.8.8
Das ist wunderbar für Azubis
Ok Hello World
Check my solution
Correct
Nice
Leute gibt es noch Fragen
Wir haben nicht mal viel Zeit in der VM
Ich glaube wir haben bloß 15 Minuten Zeit
Wir haben die 15 Minuten wahrscheinlich fast erreicht
Sudo Power Off
More Scenarios
Habe ich irgendwas überlesen
Bei dem musste ich mich ein bisschen konzentrieren
Das war schon ein bisschen komplizierter jetzt oder
Stimmt
Wir können unseren Timer verwenden
Leute
Wir verwenden das nächste mal den Timer
Sind das jetzt Admin Aufgaben oder ist das schon Bereich DevOps
Das kann man nicht so genau trennen
Seriously
Viele Admins nennen sich heute einfach nur DevOps Engineer
Weil es cooler klingt
Glaub mir ich spreche da aus Erfahrung
Das ist alles
Fließend der Übergang
Ok gab es Questions
Die ich übersehen habe
Ne
Weiter was haben wir als nächstes
Docker Container Munchpad Venice
I'm in a Container
Ok
15 Minuten Zeit
Guck mal Leute
Wir benutzen mal unseren neuen Six Head Timer
15 Minuten
Ok
Gleich geht es los
Sobald es startet
Was ist denn die Aufgabe
Try to figure out if you are inside
Inside Container
Or inside a virtual machine
Leute easy
Wisst ihr was ich einfach probiere
Mod Probe
PC Speaker
Wenn Mod Probe funktioniert
Weiß ich bin in der VM
Wenn Mod Probe fehlschlägt
Weiß ich bin im Container
Sonst noch
Man könnte
WirtWord verwenden
WirtWord
Was ich nicht installiert habe
Könnte ich verwenden
Als Root
Ja ist gut
Aber ich gehe davon aus
Das es nicht installiert ist
Wir könnten die MAC Adresse checken
Ob das bekannt ist
Ob das bekannte VM wäre
KVM oder sonst was
Mac Adressen sind
Wir könnten vielleicht
Die kernel
Commandline angucken
Mit was das OS gestartet wurde
Wir könnten gucken
Ob unser
Init Prozess
Falls wir den Init Prozess
Wobei wenn wir System D laufen haben
Ist es schonmal höchstwahrscheinlich
Kein Docker Container
Wir könnten gucken
prozess
der erste prozess ist der gestartet wurde
Keine ahnung wie man gescheit rauskriegt beim container du kannst auf punkt docker end schauen ja es gibt aber nicht nur docker als virtualisierte als
kontinuierungslösung
cpu info
das ist eine gute idee wir können gucken
hostname ctl
dem es ja gucken wir also ich probiere das mit dem köln modul köln modul dürfte das aller einfachste sein
open new window
sagt
also mod probt ob mod
mod probt ist nicht drauf
meine
scheiße
okay
mein erster ansatz funktioniert schon mal nicht dass ich einfach köln module laden kann
anders wird es wird wahrscheinlich alles nicht drauf
seine
dmi decode
alles nicht drauf
ok
hat rock cpu info da könnte man gucken
es ist ein arm die epic
Erkennt man jetzt nicht wirklich was
mein besser guest ist erst mal
mac adressen ist die ist das eine bekannte mac adresse von
irgendeiner virtualisierung lösung
Deshalb Airport
was
wenn dort
ok
Caprock
cmd laien oder so was
gut image boot
vor
cloud amd
das sieht nachher aus wobei ich mir ehrlich gesagt ich bis sie nicht sicher bin
ob das sich in einem container der auflässt
vor allem läuft einfach schlicht ergreifen ganz einfach
es genauso aussieht gibt es nicht system d detect wird ach was ist das okay wir
sind im container das habe ich ja noch nie gehört system d detect wird jepp
koch kannte dir das versuch hostname ctl ach guck mal das ist auch cool okay das muss ich
mir merken da habe ich wieder was gelernt das kannte ich selbst auch nicht haus im ctl und
system die shop rock 1 sie groups an rock 1 ja gut das ist ja innenverkehrsprozesse
mit sie groups in its gob das ist jetzt gut oder schlecht was sagt also okay wir sind in
einem container das war das wissen wir aber erkennt man jetzt daran ob es ein container
ist oder nicht aber nice nice interessantes das wusste ich nicht okay da hätte ich jetzt ein
bisschen überlegen müssen aber gut wir haben es raus bekommen wir sind in einem container
sudo power of
ach so gibt es nicht okay also next wo sind wir stehen geblieben immerhin konnte klaus in
open file ach jetzt kommt das bei leute ich kann mich nicht mehr lange konzentrieren also wir
machen wir machen das hier noch vielleicht vielleicht mal gucken aber das machen wir
auf jeden fall noch guck mal da haben wir fast die hälfte das nächste mal die schweren dinger
ok also aufgabe
wir haben eine datei Parent
some file that's up for writing by some process was haben ich Ihnen vorhin schon angeguckt
ekiloacja spiel und nobody killing the wraith ok also wir sollen die datei quasi schliessended
prozess der die datei offen hat zu killen das klingt wie nach dem siegedrück wifi signal
schicken oder so was natürlich mal gut werden wie immer
hell
Admin.
Okay.
Moment, was ist das?
Open File.sh
Also, Alice of
some
File.
Okay, die Datei ist offen.
Moment, bin ich das selbst?
Wait a minute.
Äh, warum?
Ich glaube, das ist da jetzt wieder der
Master Chibader am Werk.
Das bin ich selbst, der die Datei offen hat.
Moment.
Da ist wirklich wieder der
Master Chibader am Werk.
Ich glaube, das ist einfacher, als man denkt.
Bescher C?
Les?
Geht da irgendwas?
Okay.
Das ist gemein.
Das ist wirklich gemein.
Ich bin nur drauf gekommen,
weil ich zufällig ja hier irgendwie
Open File.sh und sowas
gesehen habe.
Okay, das ist
Chibade. Das ist richtig krasser Chibade.
Das heißt, im Endeffekt
eigentlich muss ich nur die Zeile aus der
Batch.rc löschen und es ist
gefixt. Hoffe ich mal.
Äh, zack.
Okay.
Loggen wir uns aus.
Loggen wir uns nochmal ein.
Alice of
some File.
Ups, ja, ja.
Some.
Alice of
some File.
Nix mehr. Okay.
Okay, check. Check. Solution.
Korrekt.
Das war aber gemein. Das war wirklich gemein.
Das ist wirklich Chibaded.
Der Prozess ist jetzt dead.
Ja, ja.
Der Prozess beendet sich beim Ausloggen.
Aber ich hab ihn nicht
gekillt. Das war aber
fies. Also, das ist wirklich...
Also, ich glaube, wenn du nicht zufällig
daran denkst, weil du die Dateien
gesehen hast, suchst du dich da kaputt.
Ach nee, Moment.
Power aus.
Das ist der Kram. Kostet ja Geld.
Pseudo-Power-Off.
Okay, nice.
More Scenarios.
Okay, wir hören jetzt hier auf und ich guck mir Hacker...
Ich guck mir Unix-Porn von euch an.
Machen wir das nächste Mal weiter an der Stelle.
Also, merkt euch, wir sind bis zu
Nummer... Übung Nummer 9
gekommen.
Dass man den Prozess nicht töten soll, auch nicht durch...
Ach, stand das da drinne?
Ah, okay. Dann haben wir es vielleicht nicht
auf die richtige Art und Weise gelöst.
Okay, Discord.
Ich mach mal kurz Discord auf.
Das muss ich leider am zweiten Bildschirm
machen, weil hier bin ich eingeloggt.
Aber ich kopier mir die Bilder raus.
Yep, Discord.
Äh, Channel.
Unix-Porn.
Okay.
Oder bin ich hier eingeloggt?
Discord wahrscheinlich...
Ey, Discord hab ich hier gar nicht installiert.
Aber ich müsste...
Hab ich hier echt kein Discord?
Anscheinend nicht.
Okay.
Also, weiter geht's.
Dann gucken wir uns das mal an.
Den ersten Desktop, den wir uns angucken,
ist
vom Sirius Max.
Na, das passt doch.
Modge höchstpersönlich.
Copy image.
Äh, warum ging das jetzt nicht?
Ah, Copy link.
Copy link muss ich machen.
Du hast nicht wirklich den...
Den Typ da im Hintergrund, oder?
Nur für den Screenshot, ja, ja.
Das sagst du jetzt.
Gehen die Bilder auch noch größer, wenn man die anklickt?
Nee, gell?
Oder gehen die noch größer?
Ach so! Ah, nee, nee, nee.
Die gehen auch größer.
Ich bin nur zu blöd.
Ah, hier haben wir's.
Ja, das ist kacke. Ich muss mich hier in Discord einloggen.
Sonst klicke ich mich da ja kaputt.
Ah, da bin ich ja am...
Bin ich ja drei Tage am
kopieren, bis ich das hier offen hab.
Okay, also, das ist hier...
Das ist der Linux-Desktop von unserem
Obermodge. Also,
was hat er denn am Start? Lass mal gucken.
Also, ich find farblich ist das Ganze
nochmal sehr schick gemacht. Vor allem
die
Kombination mit
Btop oder Btop++
oder wie das Ding genau heißt,
die farblich tatsächlich
zum Terminal passt. Ich könnte dir
vielleicht noch einen Tipp dafür geben.
Boah, meine Augen, Alter.
Meine Augen, Alter. Viel zu hell.
Ich könnte, ich könnte da vielleicht
einen Tipp für geben. Und zwar
ist mir auch aufgefallen, dass
der, guck mal, du kannst den Hintergrund
einstellen, wenn du hier auf Menü
gehst, Options, du kannst sagen,
dass der den Background
nicht vom Theme nimmt, sondern den Background von deinem
Terminal. Find ich persönlich schicker,
weil dann sich der
Hintergrund besser ins Terminal integriert.
Ist aber sicherlich Geschmackssache.
Aber ansonsten passt das eigentlich ganz gut.
Find ich, find ich hübsch.
Schickes, schickes Colorscheme.
Terminalfont Hack ist eh
allerbeste Terminalfont.
Endeavor OS Arch by the Way
auch beste.
Sway, also ich sehe, du verwendest Wayland.
Allerdings dann nicht in einer VM, weil
eine VM funktioniert jetzt nicht gescheit.
Ist das hier, was ist das hier oben für
eine Leiste?
Was, was hast du da am Start?
Waybar, okay.
Alles klar.
Excellent.
So, das hier ist
der Tab mit dem Browser.
Okay, du hast umgedreht, ich mach's immer so rum.
Ich mach Browser Tab 1,
Command Line Tab 2.
Das ist aber Geschmackssache.
Okay. Moment,
hab ich doppelt drauf gemacht, ja. Und hier haben wir
noch sein Visual Studio Code.
Mit selbstverständlich Blazingly
Fast written in Go.
Und er verwendet Exa, Exa
als LS Ersatz.
Bin ich ja nicht so richtig mit warm geworden
bisher. Ich hab's ne Weile verwendet,
aber ich finde immer noch Raw LS
beste.
Tuna als File Manager, vermute ich
jetzt einfach mal.
Ja, sehr schick.
Sehr schick, sieht auch alles so ziemlich
aus einem Guss aus.
Also ich vermute, dass es Tuna ist, nicht Nautilus.
Arch Entscheuer,
ja, find ich nice.
Pogu, sozusagen.
So, wen haben wir denn
als nächstes?
Sinking Face
haben wir als nächstes.
Leider nicht
allzu viele Screenshots gepostet.
Aber ein
Screenshot, der wahrscheinlich allen
Weebs unter uns gefällt.
Also wir sehen hier ein Terminal.
I3, vermute,
vermutlich I3.
Mit irgendeiner
recht minimalistischen
I3-Statusleiste.
Es scheint wohl keine VM zu sein.
Arch Linux. By the way,
was mich jetzt noch interessieren würde ist,
ist das der Hintergrund vom Terminal?
Oder ist das der Hintergrund von deinem
I3, der durchs Terminal durchschimmert?
Weil ich muss sagen,
für meinen Geschmack wär's
ein bisschen
viel Transparenz im Terminal.
Also, ein bisschen Transparenz
im Terminal find ich nice.
Das sieht optisch schick aus. Aber ich
persönlich würde die Schrift
zu schlecht erkennen mit so viel Transparenz
hintendran.
Aber ansonsten sieht er auch schick aus.
Es ist mir ein bisschen zu, also für
meinen Geschmack ist es zu
zu nah am
original I3 dran.
Und ich finde original I3
sieht nicht so schick aus.
Okay, gucken wir uns das nächste an.
Nächste kommt wieder von Modge.
Modge, und zwar
Stripes 007 kommt als nächstes dran.
Mit einem
Linux Mint, vermute ich mal.
Ja, sieht's, Linux Mint.
Pinguine im Hintergrund.
Okay, also B-Top ist
sehr beliebt anscheinend, weil's was hermacht
im Terminal. Mich würde interessieren, wie viele
von euch es wirklich regelmäßig verwenden
und H-Top vorziehen.
Hier zeug ich laufen.
Es ist ein
Linux Mint mit
Ist das ein I3? Nee, das ist kein I3.
Ist kein I3.
Ist das ein Gnome?
Ist das ein Mate?
Wobei, das steht doch hier irgendwo auch.
Gnome Terminal. Cinnamon ist es.
Cinnamon. Ach, das sind beide
Bildschirme. Das ist ein linker Bildschirm,
den er fotografiert hat, und das ist sein rechter
Bildschirm. Jetzt versteh ich das auch, warum
die Taskleiste auf einmal hier aufhört.
Okay, dann zoomen wir mal ran.
Machen wir's mal so, dass es irgendwie auf den
Bildschirm passt. Okay, es sieht
sehr klassisch Gnome-Stylich
aus. Okay, Cinnamon-Stylich
in dem Fall.
Und der eine Monitor ist auch kleiner als der andere.
Sieht aber auch ganz schick aus.
Ist halt klassischer,
recht klassischer
Desktop.
Also mehr Desktop als ein
I3. Ist aber auch schick.
Ich vermute aber,
dass das Default
Color Scheme ist. Hier sieht man
ja auch. Mint,
Dark Orange und sowas.
Also, das ist halt der Vorteil von so
vorkonfigurierten Distributionen.
Du kannst es
einfach installieren und so benutzen. Also, der
hat wahrscheinlich nicht allzu viel customised.
Sieht aber trotzdem nicht schlecht aus.
Kann man nix sagen.
Dann haben wir als nächstes
Dr. Adrian Legacy.
Haben wir als nächstes.
Okay. Alter, was
ist das für eine Font?
Das ist doch gememt, oder?
Oder benutzt
der wirklich die Font? Aber das
Farbschema ist nicht schlecht.
Ich glaube, das ist nicht
das Default Farbschema, oder?
Sieht ein bisschen heller aus,
als das Default Farbschema.
Aber der Rest sieht ziemlich Default aus.
Was hat er denn sonst noch?
Da hat er noch einen anderen
Bildschirm gepostet von sich.
Gießen.
Ah, da sieht man was es ist.
Es ist ein Pop OS.
Pop OS Gnome.
Ziemlich klassischer Standard Gnome.
Klausur.
Das ist ein Pop OS.
Pop OS mit Gnome.
Dark Theme.
Dark Theme, okay.
Gnome Terminal.
Und das letztlichste sieht man so nach seinem Desktop.
Das ist nicht so spannend.
Aber wenn das alles Default ist,
sieht auch nicht schlecht aus.
Wobei ich ehrlich sagen muss,
die Schriftart ist nicht so meins.
Pop OS, genau. Pop OS
ist das.
Gachibas.
Als nächstes haben wir Tibilius.
Tibilius hat ein ultra
Pepo White Happy Bild gepostet.
Also das ist
mega Auflösung neben seinem Bildschirm.
Oh, das sind wahrscheinlich sogar zwei Bildschirme.
Beste.
So muss das sein.
Ayaya Arch.
Okay, da hat er dran rumgebastelt.
Also er hat
einen Arch Linux
mit Gnome Default
Theme Default
Black Box Terminal.
Habe ich noch nie gehört.
A Beauty
Beautiful GTK4 Terminal.
Beautiful.
Arch by the way.
Schicken Hintergrund hat er.
Ey, Compile natürlich gerade unten was in Rust.
Was ein Poser.
Und hier oben aber noch ein Terminal.
Aber im Großen und Ganzen
ist es doch ein sehr schickes Setup.
Also farblich
auch gut aufeinander abgestimmt.
Vom Hintergrund
zur Leiste oben
zum leicht
durchschimmernden Background
vom Terminal.
Wie teilt er die Windows?
Wahrscheinlich gar nicht, sondern von Hand.
Oder man kann
vielleicht hat Gnome ja auch irgendwelche
Shortcuts dafür.
Erstmal kurz stalken was er laufen hat.
Ah.
Okay.
Ein Wine Enjoyer.
Was ist denn BTM?
Das sieht ein bisschen aus wie Hardtop nur nochmal anders.
BTM Github.
Another Cross Platform Graphical Process Monitor.
Irgendwann ist
auch mal gut.
Ach das ist written in Rust.
Ja dann. Dann ist ja alles klar.
Das muss auch sein.
Explorer X. Ja Wine
Stells. Ich finds aber
hübsch. Also ich find die Farbauswahl gut.
So diese Farbtöne.
Das passt alles richtig gut zusammen.
So als nächstes kommt Captain Paul.
Oder auch
Captain Poggers genannt.
Merkt euch das mal please.
Wo wir stehen geblieben sind.
Ich schreib mir das mal auf.
Captain Poggers.
Kommt als nächstes dran.
Ich muss jetzt nämlich mal ganz dringend aufs Klo.
Und dann
muss ich was essen.
Das heißt wir machen für heute Schluss.
Und schauen das nächste mal weiter.
Ich hoffe euch hat es gefallen Chat.
Zed
Zedke.
Ja aber die Zed Servers sind jetzt mittlerweile
White People Happy Servers.
Die sind glücklich das wir uns um sie gekümmert haben.
Und das das jetzt alles läuft.
Ja. Schön das ihr da wart.
Schön das es euch gefallen hat.
Wir machen demnächst weiter mit Zed Servers
der zweiten Hälfte.
Und gucken uns auch weiter eure Desktops an.
Vielleicht machen wir das
Desktop angucken das nächste mal am Anfang
im Stream.
Vielleicht auch gleich morgen früh oder so.
Ne machen wir lieber morgen Mittag falls
wir nochmal streamen oder am nächsten Stream dann.
Mal gucken. Alles klar ich geh jetzt was futtern Leute.
Wir sehen uns machts gut.
Bis denn.
See you.